can i uh drop a little thing about my  charity uh yeah you have to follow does  a charity go ahead um this is  it's tough to talk about but it's uh  it's a it's about a allergy it's called  cinnamon angels fly fly away and it's  for children that have cinnamon  allergies and uh it's all the money goes  to  [Music]  okay well  it's i don't know if that's a real thing  or not maybe look it made me laugh  is that a real thing  like yeah you can google it yeah yeah  yeah so i'm so sorry i'm so sorry can we  just cut it yeah there's probably uh  right now swollen ankles all right all  right all right can we just start over  and say it again and i'm so sorry that  was the [ __ ] my bad i'm so sorry